hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method you sure about that I was about
to say ask gamespot which is a show that
I watched this morning you should watch
it if you haven't seen it already asking
us well we did an episode about watch
dogs it turned out great but this show
is not asking well no this is this sean
method Wow starting strong I'm Sean
McGinnis this is peter brown hello and
today we're going to play metal gear
solid 5 ground zeroes if you guys aren't
familiar with the Sean method it's
basically a show where we just we take
video games that have rules yeah and we
break the rules yeah we know we bend
them to our own will yeah we do things
like have snake just kind of like
relaxing on the ground here and just do
like an awkward just a real cattle co
sis so this is where the target is it's
right there so the thing is we need to
get to the target which is not actually
on snakes tender underside also has
detained yeah I was gonna say the Gooch
but you know regional dialect and all
that first thing I want to do is get
this jerk attention I feel like I need
to do that by checking some magazines
his way Fisher getting his attention to
the best oh yeah right yeah right sorry
we rank possible we're spraying possible
we're not trying to do a normal run
through this oh oh hey buddy mm-hmm all
rat rat go into magazine the rat Oh what
could that be
what whose magazine is this huh oh wow
it's cool buddy you're fine just give
him a magazine do a little magazine
throw what's that huh what's happening
do you think he's gonna get angry at any
point or is he just gonna be like real
passive about it there's some kind of
rat under here who keeps throwing for
the magazines at me oh I should go tell
Zach are you shooting Ramon oh good okay
we're good oh all right you better get
that rocket launcher all right it's
about to get real hot whoo I grab this
rocket lawnchair I'm gonna pop off
there we go I'm gonna head down this way
and wait for things to cool down a
little bit [ __ ] [ __ ] all right I need I
need to disguise I'm gonna dispatch
myself as a human ok we're good all
right this guy is worn out his welcome i
don't need him anymore this I should
interrogate this guy I think that's what
I need to do my problem with sort of
information are you trying to get out of
me I just feel like if I'm gonna get
anywhere I need to interrogate this guy
with the magazine hey hey hey buddy
buddy it's cool listen I promise to you
we're fine we're fine why do I feel like
you're not going to risk I'm definitely
gonna rescue this guy all right I need
you to tell me where the secret weapons
caches tell me give me your secrets I
know you've got secrets can you give me
your secrets come on he's not telling me
anything he's just asking for help haha
this isn't go anyway they might shoot
you don't know what they don't know that
your does anything I'm just regular bill
regular bill going on his rounds in the
truck I see well to the choppers there
we go one right there right there oh now
he puts it on there and then we wait
too it's not gonna shoot what if he
shoots you all right did the truck
doesn't
vaporize that truck is dead that treads
big-time dead just a little business
there we go I got it just there no
witnesses there we go we're good okay so
which one are we doing here so this
mission you have to find a covert agent
who's working for someone other than Fox
team and you need to basically figure
out where a tape is and then kill him
you knew us you can do a Peter I have
faith in you that's okay I know I know I
know you got to pick them up carry them
around that's camouflage there you go
right now you've got that dumb sneaking
suit if you want to blend into the
surroundings you got to put on a
camouflage out where's the enemy boys
I'm looking for the enemy there guys do
you know where that enemy secret man
went really really they can see you
there right there all right so this
didn't work out as planned here I'll
show you let me I'll show you I'll show
you how
is that were you talking about okay this
is how it's done this is how an expert
performs his oh yeah so what I usually
do is I'll let them walk past me and
then I'll put the other dude just sleep
and then the guy you're trying to get is
like home huh and you give him a quick
hug and you say hey hey it's cool it's
cool i love you it's cool i'm blending
into the bushes right here right oh
there's totally not a fully grown man in
a gold rimmed sneaking suit with a bud
satchel with a butt satchel okay what
come on learn how to walk you in Oh
nards all Peter now the guys shooting at
me he turned on me some expert you
turned out to be I gotta go weapons loud
weapons allowed every you know he's
going to night-night town oh no they
show my buddy it's like they don't like
you or something oh I don't even know
what's happening everything's good up
here and as with us and the raw it's
just me and you buddy just mean you I'm
gonna wait for you to wake up and then
I'm gonna have you tell me some
information I'm just gonna set you down
right here [ __ ] spesh he didn't die
technically he fell off a cliff he's
dead though now he got shot in the butt
see that little bloody spot with his
moves he's still alive dead people can
believe I'm not go then people can bleed
oh he's asleep let him wake up throw a
couple magazines at him maybe
he's gonna he's definitely wake up wake
up it's like levitating you gotta figure
out a way for this guy to wake up oh you
don't kill him who's killing anybody
just set him down gently over there in
the open wake up I need you to give me
the location of the secret files I just
kind of he's awake you just keep wait
did you just wake him up and then
paralyze him with a dick no I didn't do
it again yeah yeah no you paralyzed him
again wake up now he's fine oh here we
go who is number two work for spin it
out we're gonna take care of him he's
gonna have a good night's sleep let's
just say that there we go and now we
create a little thing I like to call a
distress my oldest distraction there you
go I'll take care of him all that bird
that bird
I got it I got him I'll get that bird
why is that murder that Tim [ __ ]
immortal oh hello oops excuse me I'm
just trying to oh the whole mission was
just to take a bloody dead hostage oh
that is the greatest post-mission
cinematic I've ever seen all right gonna
D what is it Oh what how did we fail
we're just too good we fail we were too
good we were literally too good um but
you know all those must come doing at
all good things all see ranks things
must eventually come to an end like this
show the Shan method which is coming to
an end right now but we'll be back next
week don't worry about that by the way
if you have any suggestions for games to
play next week let me know hit me up on
Twitter at s McInnes and suggest any
games typically we've done open-world
sandbox games in your life if you guys
want to do something else it's fair game
yeah yeah it works let me know let me
know let me know all right thank you
very much Peter Brown for lending your
metal gear solid knowledge for limited
purpose yeah here on this ground series
episode of the Shan method alright guys
thanks a lot for watching I'll see you
next tuesday at 11am pacific